many parts of the United States
Constitution deal with rights of an
individual and many amendments talk
about protecting or expanding the rights
of an individual but the Fourteenth
Amendment is perhaps one of the most
important amendments in this discussion
of protecting civil rights and in
particular section one is the part that
is most cited so let's just read this
together all persons born or naturalized
the United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
United States and of the State wherein
they reside no State shall make or
enforce any law which shall abridge the
privileges or immunities of citizens of
the United States nor shall any state
deprive any person of life liberty or
property without due process of law nor
deny to any person within its
jurisdiction the equal protection of the
laws so let's just focus in on parts of
it so one big takeaway about the
Fourteenth Amendment this is the federal
government saying hey these are things
that the state cannot do so for example
when it says nor shall any state deprive
any person of life liberty or property
without due process of law this is a
restatement of the Fifth Amendment that
hey you know people can't just stick in
jail or take away your property without
you going through some type of a process
a legal process well in the Fifth
Amendment this was really talking about
the federal government not being able to
just take your property or your Liberty
away from you without the process of law
but here it's saying nor shall any state
and this Clause right over here this is
known as the Due Process Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment then right after
that it says nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction the equal
protection of the laws the equal
protection of the laws I'm going to
underline that and this you might guess
is called the Equal Protection Clause
now the context in which the Fourteenth
Amendment was ratified it happens in
1868 shortly after the end of the Civil
War you of course have the Thirteenth
Amendment that among other things
abolish slavery but then you have these
things in the South called Black Codes
which continue to repress the rights of
African Americans and that's why
Congress felt the need for the
Fourteenth Amendment to be passed now
one of the most notable cases in which
the 14th amendment was brought up
happens in 1896 Plessy versus Ferguson
and we have a whole video about this and
this is a case in which it was argued
that it was unconstitutional under the
Fourteenth Amendment for African
Americans to have to travel in a
separate train car from white Americans
and the Supreme Court infamously said
that hey as long as it is equal it is
okay for it to be separate and that
would not violate the Fourteenth
Amendment and so this idea of separate
but equal comes about
now that was significantly challenged as
we go into 1954 where you have Brown
versus Board of Education of Topeka
Kansas
Board of Education and here the argument
would was that inherently separate could
not be equal and once again the
Fourteenth Amendment was invoked and
this time the Supreme Court unanimously
ruled that yes separate can't be equal
and that the schools needed to be
desegregated so even though it wasn't an
official overruling of Plessy versus
Ferguson it was a functional overruling
of this doctrine of separate but equal
and as we go into the 1960s civil rights
movement led by folks like Martin Luther
King was a 14th amendment that was cited
often another video we're going to look
at Martin Luther King's letter from a
Birmingham jail in which he articulates
the ideas of the civil rights movement
it's a quite moving letter but once
again it's evoking these ideas of the
14th amendment and it goes on to
movements as disparate as the women's
rights movement led by organizations
like the National Organization for Women
citing equal protection of the laws in
situations of sexual discrimination in
the workplace you have pro-life groups
citing the 14th amendment arguing that
an unborn fetuses right to life is
protected by the
14th amendment you have rulings around
whether quotas in higher education are
legal or not
once again citing ideas of equal
protection of the laws so as you go
forth in your study of United States
government the 14th amendment especially
section 1 is going to keep showing up